yeah welcome to this video playing
international master go from from Russia
yeah let's try the big win yet with a
five I really need to get to those
chapters in my in my book project so
that I can actually play this with some
confidence this is a normal position the
Abdi takes e5 is very uncommon as it
doesn't really put put any pressure on
black
okay so c6 first and turn young maybe c6
yeah keep it keep it simple don't want
to spend ages here I have some
experience with this opponent he's the
kind of person who plays rook against
rook with no points on time and so
better try not to get into big-time
problems if possible
yeah this is already quite comfortable
for black it's not not better for black
or anything but looks like I don't have
any particular problems
the bishop on g2 is just biting on the
c6 pawn and he's got a slight weakness
on c4 it's not not spectacular or
anything but it's a quite comfortable
for blood okay so just go to the ATM
yeah that I can do that it's not it's
okay
yeah
kwinto kwinto c5 maybe should be okay
okay I'm even slightly ahead on the
clock really rare so how to continue
yeah it's a it's looking rather dry
but as mentioned this doesn't mean the
game is not lasting for 160 moves okay
all right maybe d4 I can argue it's an
attackable pawn we can certainly try
against this pawn but I don't really
think it's anything substantial yeah T 3
is 3
yeah but you cannot you must take on d3
cannot allow this check
we are now I intend to play rook da to
the fourth possible Jack
check jealous there's some way to play
for a win here
Jack I don't see it maybe
yeah probably this there is nothing no
history is doing something okay
yeah but what are you doing down jack
can i play hook a three maybe Alfred
look III this may be an idea can be to
the home yeah
I really don't see don't think I can can
make a big progress here computer greece
it says the repetition is the best best
you can do during probably it was a
equal for for very long time these real
was really killing the game to a draw
but maybe there is not not more both
sides I mean I'm not saying that black
head has any rights to claim it at the
natural so it's probably just just very
equal around here I was slightly
optimistic but this was was good maybe
yeah maybe I can do was something to
prevent this before I did computer wants
to play the interesting move Queen to d1
the ideas that this is he cannot take
him and this is a good idea of
threatening look at e2 now they are
Queen da to serve as a good move
strong move computer wants to go here
oops
Queen
and that this is this is somewhat more
comfortable for black if I manage to
earn to avoid this before thinks because
now it's got those pawns on the light
squares this is a bit better for black
queen d8 was strong I didn't I didn't
see the idea probably a correct draw by
both sides thanks for watching